this is the Jocko underground podcast
sitting here with Echo Charles
kind of going off The Last underground
podcast that we did and I was talking
about you know basically things are
bothering people you can let things get
under your skin
so there's a
a song
by a band called Black Flag
the song is called rise above and
the lyrics I got the lyrics I wrote down
some lyrics Here jealous cowards try to
control rise above we're gonna rise
above they distort what we say rise
above we're gonna rise above try and
stop what we do rise above we're gonna
rise above
that's the general consensus of the song
General theme of the song right
uh Black Flag
was sort of the it's one of the pioneers
of making punk rock and kind of turning
it into hardcore which is too small
musical genres and so therefore Black
Flag had a pretty big influence on my
life I had a pretty big influence on the
music that I listened to
a lot of the music that I listen to
wouldn't really exist if it wasn't for
Black Flag
Greg Ginn
um
that album that that song came out on
Rise Above it's called damage this is
the first album that they put out with
Henry Rollins singing
well I maybe a couple a month ago or
something
it popped up on my playlist you know
hell yeah and I was rocking
and
I realized how important that idea is
for so many situations that we get into
now and and the idea I'm talking about
isn't really what the song is about what
the song is about is sort of like a
rebellion song like we're gonna rise up
against them
and I get it I get that that's what the
song is about the song is about don't
let the man keep you down don't let the
man keep you down we're gonna rise above
that's what the song is about and I get
it cool but I I kind of was heard the
song the other day and I started
thinking about it from another angle and
it's really the angle that I always took
it as
I never really thought about the
political angle which is what it is
and it's us against them it's a
rebellion song I always I never really
thought about the man I kind of
think of it
in a more personal in a way it applies
to our personal lives I was talking to
Jason Gardner because Jason Gardner is
an old uh punk rocker hardcore kid like
me and we were talking about the other
day and I was saying that you know that
song has a lot of application in life
and we started talking about it
just because it's a great Mantra rise
above
because
in life
if you're not careful
there are
an infinite number of things that will
drag you down as a person whether it's
your own ego whether it's other people's
Petty egos whether it's stupid arguments
that are taking place whether it's
little slights against you those little
shots
random little emotional attacks either
from you or other people
little political maneuvering that's
going on they're gonna get that thing
they're gonna get that look
jockeying for meaningless
positions or credit like all these
little things
that can absolutely distract you they
can bother you they can drive you crazy
they can waste a bunch of your time and
effort and all you need to do
all you need to do is rise above
just rise above and that's what I
realized I was listening to this this
has probably been a mantra that I've had
in my head since I was a teenager
just this idea and look and I would say
that the the older I got the more I was
actually able to
rise above
but I do it a lot I try and do it a lot
and it it will certainly make your life
easier and better if you don't get
caught up in little things that you
can't control and that don't actually
matter anyways
rise above
easier said than done I know I get it
but maybe this will help you get there
just a little Mantra
after I told Jason about it like for the
next
three days we were together like every
time I'd see him
because it is it's a good song man it's
a good song and it's a good song to keep
in your head it's also nice because
what's nice about it is
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground